on va passer juste à la disparition
desem000 parce que il y a eu des
rebondissements aujourd'hui nouvelle
fouille en cours à quelques centaines de
mètres de la maison des grands-parents
euh on va rappeler l'histoire d'Émile à
nos téléspectateurs qui nous rejoignent
on avait parlé y a 10 jours et c'est
vrai que ça a rebondi aujourd'hui ém000
2 an et demi disparaît vers 17h
euh on découvre très vite qu'il qu'il
est il a comment dirais-je échapp à la
vigilance de ses grands-parents et en
quelques en une demi-heure il s'est
volatilisé à partir de là commence une
enquête un peu tout aimute avec des
bénévoles tous les villageois c'est un
tout petit village le hautvernis c'est
17 maisons oui et personne ne
comprend ce qui a pu se passer où est
passé cet enfant est-ce que c'est un
enlèvement est-ce que c'est un AC en
domestique est-ce que est-ce qu'il a été
renversé par une voiture chargée dans le
coffre ou fa plus de 2 mois maintenant
et ça fait maintenant 2 mois c'était
début juillet le 8 ou le 9
juillet et à partir de depuis 2 mois on
l'enquête piétine je crois qu'il y a 90
hectares qui ont été ratissés par les
les gendarmes hélicoptèr caméras
thermique enfin tous les moyens
possibles et envisageables ont été mis
en mis en place après ils se sont
recentrés en limitant un petit peu le le
monde sur le terrain parce qu'ils sont
quand même rendu compte que ça ne
donnait rien d'une part et que de deux
s'il y avait une une scène de crime euh
ça risquait quand même de de de saboter
cette scène de crime donc ils sont ils
se sont recentrés sur le
village ils ont fermé le village ils
sont pleuré que que les choses a un peu
bougé ces derniers jours quelles sont
les dernières informations concernant
l'enquête euh sur alors depuis lundi
depuis lundi les
gendarmes se sont attaqués à une dalle
de
béton qui qui qui est sur une une maison
qui est à quelques centaines de mètres
du domicile des grands-parents cette
dalle de béton elle a été coulée quand
alors coïncidence la dalle de béton est
coulée de façon concomitante avec la
disparition de des 1000 donc le même
jour on dit que c'est le même jour c'est
le même jour donc de là à faire le
rapprochement évidemment on peut pas en
faire l'économie et d'ailleurs déjà au
tout début des investigations c'est au
début de au moment de la disparition de
des m000 les gendarmes avaient sondé
cette dalle de béton avec un un sonnard
et ils avaient trouvé
une une anomalie dans l'utilisation du
sonard sonard ça ça permet de
détecter c'est la densité du béton
c'estd que alors justement parce que ça
c'était la densité du béton VZ n dire on
va rebondir dessus et donc qu'est-ce
qu'est-ce qu'il disait il y avait une
anomalie d'accord donc ils ont cassé
l'endroit où il considérait qu'il y
avait une anomalie et en réalité bah la
densité du béton était peut-être pas la
même partout sur la dalle peut-être plus
de ça plus de gravier plus de béton j'en
sais rien l'information c'est cette
dalle de béton coulé le jour même de la
disparition des miles qui a témoigné
pour dire que c'était le même jourant
parce que c'est c'est des informations
qu'on vient d'avoir alors que cétait
quand même une information qui est quand
même capitale alors il y a les ouvriers
qui qui ont qui ont qui ont coulé cette
dalle il y a un certain nombre de
témoins parce que c'est un tout petit
village où tout se sait où tout se voit
et donc du coup le le rapprochement a
été fait et ça restait une une porte
entrouverte dans l'enquête et du coup
les gendarmes depuis lundi ont casser
l'intégralité de cette dalle de béton
pour comme on dit lever le doute pour
être certain de pas passer à côté d'une
est-ce trouve-vous cette dalle de béton
la dalle de béton elle se trouve il y il
y un deux mais celle qui nous intéresse
se trouve dans le garage de d'une maison
qui a été racheté par des des gens du
coin en janvier et pourquoi ils ont fait
cette dalle de béton maintenant alors
ils
ont ils ont racheté cette maison ils ont
voulu faire des travaux des travaux un
peu d'envergure ils ont fa ils en
faisaient tout le temps ces travauxou
bien il venaient de l'acheter la maison
d'accord il venit de l'acheter il en
janvier oui ils étaient en janvier donc
bon oui mais ça il y avait d'autres
choses à faire peut-être avant c'était
peut-être pas la priorité et peut-être
qu'il faut une température précise pour
que le béton tienne je sais pas la
question qu'on se pose c'est que les
enquêteurs sé attardés sur cette dalle
de béton il y a 2 mois et demi ouais et
bizarrement aujourd'hui est-ce qu'ils
auraient des éléments qui font qu'ils se
sont attardés à nouveau sur cette dalle
de béton hier et aujourd'hui a priori
non euh alors pourquoi ils sont
retournés là-bas ils sont retournés
là-bas parce que ça restait une porte
entrreouverte dans l'enquête et comme
ils ont rien d'autre ils sont dit on
peut pas prendre le risque de de de
passer à côté si ça se trouve en cassant
on va découvrir le le corps de cet
enfant et en tout cas on leur aurait
reproché de ne pas l'avoir fait si si
avaitt le cas de mois je comprends pas
oui parce qu'ils ont dû faire autre
chose en cours de
route ça ça risquait je sais pas ça j'ai
pas la réponse alors il y a un autre
élément dont on on va revenir dessus
dans un instant mais juste oui parce que
ils ont interrogé pendant 3h et 2h les
anciens l'ancien propriétaire et les
nouveaux propriétaires et que ils ont
euh réussi aussi à obtenir les noms des
gens de l'entreprise de BTP du Sud qui a
procédé aux travaux et ils se sont dit
comme vous que la concomitance était
improbable il y a pas de coïncidence en
matière de fait d'hiver donc ils ont
voulu effectivement fermer cette porte
en cassant toute la dalle au marteau
piqueer avec des équipements terribles
et visiblement voilà visiblement il y a
rien sous la dalle mais ils ont pensé à
un moment que la la la coïncidence des
dates était trop extravagante pour qu'il
n'y ait rien voilà il pouvait pas en
faire l'économie on est d'accord qui
prolonge la bergerie eux-mêmes se sont
dit mais il y avait-il nécessité de
construire une dalle qui prolonge une
bergerie donc ça a attiré leur attention
énormément cette dal et bien elle est
chez des nouveaux propriétaires qui
habitent je crois à Marignan hein voilà
à quelques kilomètr pas très loin dans
la région et donc ils se sont dit mais
pourquoi est-ce que des gens achètent en
janvier construisent à l'été qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé est-ce que c'est lié
voilà a priori non mais néanmoins que
ces personnes ont été entendu ou pas oui
oui oui 3 plusieurs heures très
précisément pour voir s'il y avait des
mensonges des contradictions dans les
déclarations de l'ancien propriétaire
des nouveaux propriétaires voilà c'est
pour ça qu'il voulait fermer cette porte
effectivement la maman éta entendue
aussi ce et ce weekend il s'est passé
quoi la maman de petitm elle a été
entendue ce weekend ou elle ou c'est ça
elle a été entendue très régulièrement
et plusieurs fois c'est encore ce
weekend j'ai pas le j'ai pas la
précision sur ce sur ce weekend
peut-être il réentendre toute la famille
effectivement la maman et ils veulent
établir l'emploi du temps précis de tout
le monde donc c'est une cartographie des
lieux mais aussi de chaque minute
utilisé si je puis dire par chacun des
protagonistes qu'est-ce que vous faisiez
et il y a ce fameux témoin vous savez on
avait parlé de deux témoins alors on
aura peut-être demain sur le plateau he
voilà alors il y a il y a un témoin qui
dit qu'il a vu le petit près de la
cabane qu'il construisait et il y a un
témoin qui dit qu'il l'a vu descendre
vers le lavoir voilà et l'un de ces deux
on a un témoin demain qui sera de mais
qui voilà quelqu'un du village qu'on
avait dà entendu et donc l'un de ses
témoins dit que possiblement au moment
où le petit descend le grand-père coupe
du bois à côté voilà donc ils essayent
d'établir l'emploi du temps précis du
dernier moment où on a vu Émile il y a
encore des contradictions mais ils
remontent et ils ont fait aussi quelque
chose de de normal mais incroyable je
crois qu'ils ont examiné les caméras
vidéos de 1500 distributeurs de billet
de banque dans la région pour voir si
quelqu'un de
suspect inconnu ou connu par eux par les
enquêteurs aurait pu retirer des billets
et cetera donc vidéo surveillance et
téléphonie ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui et
à 21h10 en direct et ce qui est assez
troublant c'est que on voit qu'ils
avaient étendu les recherche assez loin
et on sent que les la gendarmerie la
police réduit vraiment au village donc
c'est qu'ils ont peut-être des éléments
ou peut-être voilà une conviction que ça
se serait passer vraiment dans un
périmètre très très très très petit et
que ce serait dans le village he c'est
ce qui ressort puisque ils ont
complètement stoppé les recherches un
peu plus loin et là on a l'impression de
de de l'extérieur et de j'ai passé de
trois C fil aujourd'hui qu' auraient
voilà ils ont ils commencent à avoir
quelques éléments de ce qui se dirait et
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont revenus sur
cette DLE de béton aujourd'hui Michel
c'est ça ou pas c'est tout à fait ça
c'est la c'est le principe de la
l'enquête escargot c'est quand on on
part du centre on s'éloigne et quand on
trouve rien on revient dans l'autre sens
pour recentrer euh sur les origines
c'estàdire le village Jacques dans dans
des dans dans ce genre d'enquête la
dimension psychologique elle est
extrêmement importante donc quand on
patine les enquêteurs refont en fait
plusieurs fois le même film et
réentendent les gens et essaent de les
confondre avec des éléments qui peuvent
avoir et parfois il arrive que des gens
craquent que les attitudes ne soient pas
les mêmes que les gens soient face à une
contradiction que le temps passant les
propos changent et donc tout ça peut
servir les enquêteurs donc ils
reviennent sur des points qui sont pas
forcément déterminants mais qui sont
sensibles et qui peuvent les emmener
après euh vers des éléments plus probant
ce qui est sûr Cyril c'est que dans
cette enquête il y a eu plusieurs
hypothèses et c'est vrai que ça fait un
moment que ça se resserre totalement euh
sur ce village dont on sait dont on sait
que tout se sait et on le disait la
dernière fois il y a forcément des gens
qui savent qui ont des éléments mais qui
peut-être n'ont pas tout dit et c'est
cette technique d'enquête qui peut à un
moment donné faire basculer lieu clos
village qui se termine en impasse très
peu de maisons très peu de protagonistes
donc lieu clos et les entraîneurs et les
les enquêteurs maintenant se disent h
clos voilà drame d'un h clos comme les h
clos à la Gata Christi où tu sais qu'il
y en a 10 des 10 l'IM que personne ne
parle personne ne parle alors personne
ne parle mais néanmoins ça a déjà été
révélé mais on peut le dire tout le
monde est sur écoute euh et les
enquêteurs utilisent beaucoup beaucoup
tout ce qu'ils ont entendu en off au
téléphone et tout ce que leur ont dit
les gens et là ils vont mettre ça en
parallèle et voir effectivement qui m
qui dit la vérité on a le sentiment
Michel que là on on a on avance plus
plusque il y a de semaines dans
l'enquête j'espère en tout cas il faut
pas désespérer une enquête c'est long
par
définition dans ce dans ces milieuxl
c'est
compliqué ils font en tout cas tout ce
qui est en leur pouvoir pour essayer de
faire avancer les choses euh là le
l'anecdote enfin l'anecdote c'est pas
une anecdote mais le euh ce qu'ils ont
fait avec les les les terrasses euh
c'était indispensable de casser les
dalles de béton c'était indispensable il
pouvait pas une fois de plus en faire
l'économie et je crois même que c'est
les propriétaires qui ont demandé aux
gendarmes de ou au juges d'accélérer les
les choses pour entre guillemets crever
l'abset parce que ça restait en suspens
cette histoire et eux voulaient pouvoir
continuer à faire leurs travaux en
disant vous êtes bien gentil mais euh si
vous pensez que l'enfant est là allez-y
casser tout euh et après on on aura on
aura le cœur net et on pourra parce
qu'ils était pas forcément dans le
collimateur peut être quelqu'un le
meurtrier celui qui aurait enlevé cet
enfant qui aura été le déposer là et un
enfant de 2 ans et demi ça prend pas
beaucoup de place merci merci à vous
tout de suite Marie sur C V merci
beaucoup